hello steve kaufman here again and today
i have the pleasure of speaking with
will john
someone that i spoke to about a year ago
you may remember
and we're going to talk about a variety
of things having to do with language and
maybe sports but first remember if you
enjoy these videos please subscribe
click on the bell for notifications
and if you follow me on a podcast
service please leave a comment i do
appreciate it
uh will
uh
you were when we last spoke you were a
soccer player with an interest in
languages
maybe you can update us on what you've
been doing yeah so
uh i'm still a soccer player with a
massive interest in languages
but this time around
we've started a project called goluremi
languages where essentially we just walk
around the street and kind of surprise
people
with our language ability and uh the
idea behind the channel is to display
everything that we've learned and also
to talk about the methods uh that we use
in order to actually
make this happen and uh we share a lot
of similarities uh you and i have both
been influenced uh quite heavily as a
matter of fact
it was actually
pretty much well over a year that we
talked
you introduced the name stephen krashen
to me i had already been using
comprehensible input to some some degree
without even knowing who he was and
since then i've spoken to him and all
this stuff so we we have a lot of
similarities in our methods
but uh that's that's that's what's going
on so now we've got this golder
languages uh youtube channel and tick
tock that's uh kind of taken off
and uh it's given us a chance to you
know to step outside of the world of
football or soccer uh briefly you played
soccer professional soccer in a number
of countries just update my list yeah so
uh you know i was uh
i'm from kansas city in in the us and i
started my career playing in the mls so
i played for the chicago fire uh and
then i played two years in my hometown
sporting kansas city before moving to
europe playing in the danish super
league
so i played there and i played in serbia
i played uh back in finland for a couple
years
[Music]
croatia where i play now uh so
yeah it's it's been an interesting
journey
you know i can't resist
in spain speaking to an american about
soccer
i can't resist reminding you that canada
oh
my god
yes sorry
i just wanted to say
you won't remember you don't remember
in our
in our first interview i'm almost
certain that we talked about soccer we
talked about canada and i said canada
was on the up and up and you were like
oh that's surprising and here we have
proof of this now in this two-zero win
so
canada is a darkness without their star
without allah without their star player
exactly
it is it is it is you guys are coming up
all right anyway leaving that because
i'm sure that the americans will be back
so
we crow while we can crawl
but
uh your interest in languages is this as
a result of you traveling and being in
because the average person from kansas
city let's say probably doesn't see a
tremendous need for learning language
yeah
so what was it about your background
that made you interesting um
the traveling is not a part of it
everyone assumes that because uh i
traveled around i learned all these
languages when i was in the country
nothing could be further from the truth
of course yes when i played in croatia
when i played in denmark i did learn
those languages there but uh i've spent
three or four days in italy and i speak
italian uh i learned french before ever
living or playing in a french speaking
country
um
german is the same the catalyst for my
language learning is my mother uh who is
unfortunately passed away but she
decided at a young age that it would be
better for me to come home and not watch
i don't know pokemon or whatever it was
that i wanted to watch as a kid and she
said nope you're watching this and this
was a comprehensible input as it turns
out
for kids to learn spanish as a second
language
and so i without knowing it by the time
i was around somewhere between 10 and 13
had a pretty good grip on spanish and uh
that got me to realize that i i'd
learned the language without much effort
at all as you know from this uh the the
method and the way that you know you
guys do do things over link
you're not really forcing too much you
know you don't stress people to speak
and do all this so so that was a huge
factor and then the book i read the book
counter monte cristo and that basically
sent me have you read it
have you read that book by chance it was
a long time
yeah sure well the character just struck
me as a 16 year old that he had this
ability to travel around the world that
he took all this time and he learned
these languages while he was in prison
and all this stuff and then he had this
ability to just travel and do everything
i really it struck me and that's
that's the real reason
why i can do this i'd like to get back
to the whole subject of motivation
because it's such a big part of language
learning but first
i'm curious to know you know it's been
more than a year since we last spoke
you've now launched your youtube channel
you've got some videos that have gone
viral can you update us on what you yeah
so uh we we stopped and i think it was
at the end it might have even been just
off air in the last uh you asked you
know
and i said uh in english no
because i just got into sweden
and uh so yeah i i
i learned
swedish you know at a comfortable level
now that i can communicate and now it's
been been great uh
you know the motivation and it's so
interesting for all the people out there
that are that are
trying to learn it's
it's regardless of the language and it's
just something i just i like to hammer
into people who are here that have just
started their language journey or are
about to
you will be super motivated at the
beginning you will gain uh quite a bit
at the beginning thanks to you will hit
a dip
it is guaranteed you might not hit it in
10 days you might not hit it in a week
but it will come you will stall at some
point and you've just got to push
through that dip uh you might even need
to take a break
i'm not saying to quit uh you know if
you've lost all passion for it then it
might not have been the best choice but
if you're still interested in it that
dip part right there is the is the
turning point because if you can get
through the dip and stick to it and keep
your passive listening up and and a
little active listening and a little bit
active speaking stuff like that
you generally
start this
exponential jump
up uh if you know if you're following
the method correctly so
um yeah you know uh i would say just to
be aware of that because motivation will
wane uh you know when you you pop into a
conversation that you you feel like oh
my god i can't understand anything what
am i doing with my life you know so then
so uh and so you're motivated obviously
to learn languages you're also motivated
to help people learn languages i can
sense your enthusiasm passion and so
forth and how so what are you actually
what are the the kinds of activities
that you have gotten yourself involved
in language learning
oh gosh yeah you said something about
you're on the youtube oh gosh yeah so uh
so right now we filmed
languages languages yes go check it out
so golorami is the name of our obviously
we have a we have a rather large uh
soccer youtube channel and soccer
company named golorami my middle name is
oluremi and we just put the word g for
gold the spanish word goal so we mash
that together
exactly
and um
yeah so we have filmed
videos language videos in i believe
sweden in croatia we just did one in new
york where we spoke to
uh we went to little italy and just
wanted to find out if people there could
speak italian and that video
has been popped all over places and
we're gonna
we've just been asked to be a part of
documentary now from from that video and
all this stuff so uh you know we've had
some some guys and that's obviously our
goal is to is to reach people like you
as well to kind of give people a good
base of language learning understanding
to tackle it from different ways i mean
i think
right one of the things that you see in
this is that
many of the successful polyglots uh like
you they have certain different methods
but they they all have a few things that
are just
they have to luca lampariello uses this
but steve also uses this they might
differ on a few little things right but
it's just clear that there's a pattern
uh there and we want to kind of point
that out for people so that's that's the
goal of the channel and that's what
you'll find there and that's kind of
just what we've been up to is is uh
speaking people in the street
in these different languages shocking
them doing some of these omegle videos
that you've seen online where you kind
of shock people those are always fun the
reaction's great and then the other goal
is to simply educate people on the best
methods because it is truly probably
still plural even though there's a lot
of similarities
and uh you know making it simple for
people to do that that's it that's what
we're about uh you know you mentioned
the dip that's interesting because
one of the reasons for that dip is that
when we start into a new language we
achieve a fair amount of success
initially from knowing nothing about the
language not understanding anything all
of a sudden we can understand something
we can say something we're very
impressed with ourselves
but then the reality is that the word
frequency declines very very quickly
so that uh in the initial few months
we're meeting the same words over and
over again and then suddenly as we start
to hit
words that don't appear that often it's
harder and harder to remember them and
that's where it's i think so important
to get into
content of interest you can actually get
to something that you're actually
interested in hearing about and reading
about then that sort of the interesting
nature of the content will keep you
going because i have not found like
after that i consider it more of a
plateau sure that's good not like you
have a sudden dip and then all of a
sudden you take off again
you settle into a sort of a long
distance you start off sprinting and
pretty soon you realize this is a long
distance it's a 50 kilometer this is the
90 kilometer vasaloppet in sweden it's a
long road
yeah anyway yeah yeah
but i agree with you that the the
successful language learners the word
polyglot is a bit intimidating most
english speakers don't even know the
word uh but successful language learners
have many many things in common what are
some of the main things in common that
you have found
that's a really good question so what we
have found so far and obviously we
haven't made the exhaustive uh list yet
but what it's clear
a good understanding of why they're
starting to to learn the language
they chose even if they want to learn
many languages they generally the
successful ones the ones and by
successful i mean that they a relative
a relatively short amount of time is is
used to learn the language one year six
months uh you know something like this
not like 10 years to learn
one
one new language
uh they choose they choose that language
out of a
absolute huge desire they focus then on
one language
for the most part now it's not that most
polyglots do choose uh don't don't study
more than one language but what tends to
happen is uh one becomes more of a focus
one language kind of rules out in the
brain uh you know and uh it it seems
that
they have a main they have a main focus
it uh you know you might end up dreaming
in this and doing things like that
the other is the frequency like you
we've kind of touched on but it's every
day regardless of if it's five minutes
and people just cannot quite yet
understand the importance of this but
the exposure that you have in your
mother tongue
is enormous and you got it every day
when you're a kid whether you liked it
or not uh because you didn't control
your environment and if you're looking
to learn another uh language
you cannot have these massive gaps
that's something that all polyesters do
not have in their success they do not
have like a six to seven day
you know just to stop in the middle of
their their their learning
it's a constant everyday thing uh
comprehensible input as we've kind of
spoken about and for the people that
steve can probably explain it much
better than i can uh but comprehensible
input
is
a
and i the way that i describe it is most
polyglots if they don't know about it
early on they will stumble on
and find it they will stumble their way
to it through all the methods maybe the
apps and the
extensive grammar research that they
make us do in all schools and and stuff
which doesn't tend to you know have a of
a great success rate
uh
those are those are the the key factors
um that is more or less what what we
found um
everything else outside of that is a bit
supplemental um so being able to focus
being able to constantly obviously
there's things like concentration you
can i've talked about meditation with
some guys i know what they do before
they study and that's something that i'm
huge into deep work you know being able
to shut off your phone being able to
these these sort of things will amplify
your your
your ability to learn and uh they
shouldn't necessarily be taken seriously
because the best guys do do that and i
think uh that's that's
that's something that can't be taken for
granted you know um
in the whole in the whole journey right
and of course the trigger
is motivation
and the motivation can be as you say it
can be you know focused on one language
but i don't want to discount the people
who are just curious about languages and
who study a lot of
i
languages
the stereotype is that someone from the
heartland of north america is not going
to be interested in languages
and i can't help but when we talk about
people who dabble in a lot of languages
furious who were curious about a lot of
languages i can't help but remember
moses mccormick i don't know if you're
familiar with we are
sorry to interject and i i should just i
i just want to put this in here because
it's actually kind of tragic i mean
obviously we all know moses story but
moses and i right before obviously glory
language got started just uh
just recently
moses and i had been in uh
exchange we've been in a constant
exchange because he was not too far from
me when i was always in the u.s
and we continually we continually kind
of pushed it back we keep we kept
delaying it because it was just like oh
i come home every six months i come home
you know i'll be home we'll be able to
do it and we'll do this cool level up
together you know these two
african-american guys he speaks a lot of
asian languages i speak some eastern
european languages and it would just
blow up the internet with this cool
cool thing and we kept delaying it we
kept delaying it and then i woke up one
day and he had passed away
and it was just like
wow
he's extremely tragic and aside from his
see what what impressed me with him was
first of all he was a very generous
person generous with his time
and he was uh he had a very gentle
storytelling casual approach which i
found very effective
but the big thing about him i think from
the point of view of language learners
is his curiosity so he wasn't learning a
language because he had a girlfriend
get a job or
work for a company he was genuinely
curious in languages and i think
successful language learners they have
to have curiosity if you aren't curious
about another language how it works in
other culture it's difficult to drum up
the motivation even if you have a
girlfriend or a boyfriend or whatever it
is you have to be curious
and and the other thing about him is he
comes from he came from a background
like it's not like he went to a prep
school
i mean i gather he grew up what's known
in the states as the projects or
something so it's not like a
tremendously stimulating environment and
so i don't know what stimula what's got
him going with you know but obviously
you can be in any situation if you have
that level of curiosity
uh and and you are disciplined enough to
you know commit the time necessary you
can learn focus on one language you can
focus on a number of languages but it's
got to start with curiosity
so i think that's a big part of what for
sure yeah no i mean by no means i would
want to deter anyone from studying more
than one language i mean i do i do do
that now especially this you know moses
had such a incredible ability to draw on
his knowledge and just to kind of get
these things to stick for him he may not
have had you know an in-depth knowledge
of macedonian for instance but he spent
enough time in that and he didn't
pretend no by no means and it doesn't
matter and i hope that that people get
that point too right that's not the
point here
of i mean i i've hardly rarely have seen
any any any uh
successful language learner that says
that you have to speak perfectly
otherwise don't do it don't start and i
think a lot of people have that issue
they have that block and it's it stops
people from
from speaking or from trying and stuff
like that so so yeah i know if you're if
your goal is i'm just interested in kind
of just connecting with people because
honestly if you can just learn two words
in another language and it's a random
language and you meet these people and
you say the word
it's over you guys are best friends if
you just spoke a little swahili to the
guy yeah you know
i'm sure you've had that so oh yeah
so what i would suggest now because
we're also going to do an interview here
for will's channel and we're going to
leave a link to will's channel in the
description box
and in that interview will's going to
ask me a bunch of questions i'm not
quite sure what but one of the things
we're going to do is to speak in
different languages so if you want to
hear us speak in different languages i
suggest that you mosey on over to will's
channel for the continuation of this
discussion and we'll just end it here
but thank you very much
for uh coming on on my channel all right
yeah and there will be problems thanks a
lot good to be back